pas d'expulsion possible d'un locataire
jusqu'au 31 mars 2022 c'est la notion
que l'on connaît le plus de la trêve
hivernale né en
1956 mais il ya des exceptions comme
ceux bénéficiant d'un relogement les
squatteurs ou en corse ayant commis des
violences mais qui dit trêve hivernale
ne dit pas fin des obligations pour les
locataires si les personnes concernées
par cette trêve ne sont plus redevable
du loyer elle le son d'une indemnité
d'occupation fixé par le jul qui
équivaut au montant du loyer et des
charges en cas de difficultés à payer
son loyer il existe des solutions on
vaut mieux continuer à payer autant que
faire se peut un l'entente que ce moment
il ya six des locataires de bonne foi
qu'ils ne peuvent pas payer tout
simplement mais là il faut te faire des
démarches à gspon social peut-être un
dossier de surendettement mais toujours
payé le plus possible pour aussi que la
caf ait envie de continuer à verser les
apl et éviter que la dette à la sortie
sous la catastrophique la trêve
hivernale concerne aussi les
propriétaires bailleurs en cas de non
respect de cette trêve d'une peine de
prison allant jusqu'à trois ans et 30000
euros damende sont possibles
interdiction aussi de procéder à des
coupures d'électricité de gaz et de
l'eau les propriétaires bailleurs ont
aussi des droits 6e il ya un an
ils ont besoin de ce loyer pour payer
les mensualités de crédit puisqu'ils ont
achetés notamment pour l'investissement
locatif ils pourront obtenir un délai de
grâce auprès du juge qui peut suspendre
un du coup les mensualités durant deux
ans il peut aussi négocier avec la
banque qui peut elle aussi suspendre par
contre la banque très rarement vassues
spanneut suspendra pas les intérêts donc
l'intérêt continu un groupe courir mais
ces deux options ils peuvent eux mêmes
se mettent en surendettement la trêve
hivernale prendra fin le 31 mars 2022
c'est les expulsions concernent très
régulièrement d1p l'adil note une
augmentation des motifs liés aux
troubles du voisinage